Fish have been found singing off the coast
of Australia.
A belated Prince tribute, you ask?
Well, no, not exactly.
Hey guys, Natalia here for DNews today.
The morning rooster has met its underwater
match.
Scientists have studied fish since the days
of Aristotle, analyzing their body language
and vocal behavior, but recent recordings
off the coast of Australia have identified
some new overlapping fish songs, particularly
at dusk and dawn.
In a study published in the journal Bioacoustics,
researchers found seven new fish sounds in
coastal waters off Port Headland, Australia.
They discovered this by recording groups of
fish over an 18-month period and found unique
choral patterns—overlapping ‘solos’
that created a melody.
But interestingly, they don't create these
vocalizations using vocal chords.
In fact, the term ‘vocalization’ is a
bit of a misnomer, according to researchers.
There are many ways fish can sing – by gnashing
their teeth, snapping the tendons of their
pectoral fins together, and more commonly,
by contracting and vibrating their swim bladder
against their sonic muscle.
The swim bladder isn’t a bladder like we
know it.
It’s actually an air-filled sac found inside
the body of many fish that acts like a drum
to amplify sound.
Not all fish have a swim bladder, but the
species that do will come to the surface to
“gulp” air that is then directed into
the sac.
The sonic muscle is attached to the swim bladder
to create sound.
When the swim bladder fills with air, it vibrates
against the muscle, producing a low-pitched
drumming..
In an Oyster Toadfish, the sonic muscle can
contract at a rate of 200 times per second
– that’s more than double the speed that
a hummingbird flaps its wings.
Now, all fish can hear, but not all can make
sound.
Of the 20,000 different known species of fish,
only about 800 are believed to make noise.
The ones who can have been known to produce
‘croak,’ ‘purr,’ or popping type sounds,
but the study unveiled a new variety of sounds
along the ocean floor – from a low “foghorn”
type call by the Black Jewfish, to a grunting
buzz-sound from a species of Terapontid, to
a quieter, lower “ba-ba-ba” type call
from a Batfish.
And researchers think that fish have many
reasons to cause a clatter: to attract mates,
reproduce, defend their territory, warn of
danger, scare off predators, and hunt their
own prey.
Even more interesting is how the types of
noise differ by time of day.
In a 2015 study published in the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences researchers
found daytime fish calls overlapped with each
other, like in a crowded room, while nighttime
fish calls were more singular and distinct.
This suggested that since day-swimming fish
can see each other, they can use visual cues
to communicate and therefore can afford to
muddle their sound -- like talking over each
other.
But at night, fish can only tell other species
apart by the noises they make, so they are
a little more distinctive.
So next time you find yourself swimming with
the fish, keep your ear to the ground…er,
the ocean floor, and you may just hear their
frequencies -- the complex choruses of the
underwater world.
Many fish in the ocean make their homes in
coral reefs, but those reefs are in danger.
Our sister show Seeker Stories takes a look
at one unlikely source of reef destruction
- feral pigs.
Check it out here.
Ever wonder what effect human noise has on
marine life?
Let us know what you’re curious about, and
like this video to subscribe for a new episode
of DNews every day of the week.